hey I'm Daniel molar and I'm going to
talk about sub quadratic algorithms for
six think stable matching and this is
joint work with Mohan to Terry and
Stefan Schneider so there's many
situations where you have members of two
disjoint sets that you want to pair up
with each other for example you might
have doctors who want to match with
residency programs or economists like
caring about buyers and sellers in a
market or there's matching computer
scientists with the academic jobs
available and and even dating and these
situations can often be in flux like
people are hired and fired and get
promoted etc and there's openings and
people might be dating and then someone
find someone else they like better and
and this causes a lot of overturn and
shift and what what we ideally want is
we want some more stability in this
setting so in the stable marriage
problem were given two disjoint sets
classically called men and women and
we're given a preference list for each
participant and the goal is to find a
matching with no blocking pairs so what
we mean by that is suppose we had a
matching where there was a brown haired
man mesh with a brown the brown haired
woman and the black haired man was
matched with the black haired woman now
suppose for whatever reason the
black-haired woman would rather be with
the brown haired man and the brown
haired man would rather be with the
black haired woman now these two would
want to break up with their partners and
pair with each other and this is often
considered to be bad in many social and
economic settings so we want to find a
matching with no such blocking pairs and
that would be a stable matching
galen shapely came up with an algorithm
the deferred acceptance algorithm to
find a stable matching and in this
algorithm the men make proposals down
the order of their preference list until
they're accepted and the women will
accept the best of all the proposals
that they received this algorithm is
quadratic time which is actually optimal
especially considering that the input
size to the general problem is quadratic
it takes quadratics place to represent
all of the preference list however it's
natural to ask the question of whether
you actually need to look at the entire
preference list when you're finding a
stable matching but the answer for this
is also that it requires still requires
quadratic time to compute stable
matching and even to verify a stable
matching that was shown by these results
here so we want to know if what happens
if we can have more succinctly some sort
of underlying constraints that constrain
the stable matching preferences
sometimes people might have very similar
preferences if they're very correlated
sometimes it's also just not possible to
list all participants for example you
can't possibly list your preferences
over the entire population of the United
States because you would have to get to
know everyone enough to figure out who
you like better and in these cases so if
we have preferences that are no longer
quadratic space can we now do better in
stable matching in particular we'll look
at the d list and d attribute model
which were proposed by bat nagar
Greenberg and randall so 4d attribute
preferences we have d different
attributes and the preferences and
participants have a score according to
each attribute for example if you do
online dating typically they'll give you
a score based on your income your height
your personality and you also have your
own preferences over what your
for in a partner some people care more
about looks and some people care more
about personality etc and also you have
in universities universities are ranked
according you know by US News and World
Report according to their academics
their social life and how good the
football team is doing and different
students are looking for different
things in their our college experience
so in this setting we have D fixed
attributes and scoop the scores are
fixed according to those attributes and
the participants preferences are simply
determined by a linear combination of
the weight and the attribute so as a
quick example here we have three
attributes and we have these four women
that all have scores according to the
attributes and so let's take man m his
weight vector is 0 half half which means
that he doesn't care at all about the
first attribute and he waits the other
two the second and third equally so his
preference list would be given there
which you can just see by just adding up
the second or third vectors to see what
who's the best
the other model is the d-list
preferences and here the idea is that
different certain groups might share the
same preferences for example
student-athletes might have the same
they might be looking for the same thing
sorority members might be looking for
the same thing etc and so we have D
different lists and each participant
just picks one of them to use as their
preferences and mathematically this is a
special case of the D attribute setting
but it's motivated slightly differently
and we also have some stronger results
for it so that's why we consider it as
well so as an example of two lists
preferences you have two lists of men
sigma1 sigma2 two lists of women pi-1
and pi2 and each man chooses one of the
pie one or pie too and each woman
chooses Sigma one or Sigma 2 okay so
what do we want to ask about this we
want first we want sub quadratic
algorithms since the space is no since
both of these models are linear space we
want to see if we can do better than the
quadratic Gail shapely in particular we
want to find a stable matching ideally
we'll look for one with arbitrary waists
and attributes arbitrary real or energy
values we could if we can't find that we
can look at small integers or boolean
attributes and weights and we can also
look for the d-list preferences
and then we also want to ask the same
questions about verifying a stable
matching because in the general case
verifying is as hard as finding a stable
matching so for our results we have a
sub quadratic algorithm for constant D
for the D attribute model and this is
for a special one sided case in this
case the women's preferences are all the
same so there's one ranking of men that
all the women use and the men's that
preferences are generated by the D
attribute model and so we have a sub
kajak algorithm for this case the we
also can have a sub quadratic algorithm
when the weights and integers are from a
small set of size c we can verify of
stable matching also in sub quadratic
time for constant D in the general to
attribute model and here we don't have
the one-sided restriction this is a
truly sub quadratic for the real value
real valued attribute and weight model
we have an order D and algorithm for the
d-list model and this is actually
optimal because the input size is order
d times n so we're happy with this
algorithm and we also have a randomized
algorithm for boolean weights and
attributes for verifying a stable
matching and this is where D is C log in
and this uses essentially the same
techniques that Ryan talked about
yesterday
so finally we have a hardness result so
there's no sort of strongly sub
quadratic algorithm for D is little
Omega of log in assuming stuff like most
of the talks in this workshop and this
is actually for both finding and
verifying so once there gets to be even
not too many but reasonable amount of
attributes we can no longer hope to do a
so-so quadratic algorithms and this uses
a reduction from maximum inner product
which is known to be stuff hard so first
I'm going to sketch the hardness result
and then I'll show one of the algorithms
and we'll finish so in the we need to
use the maximum inner product so in
maximum inner product we're given a two
sets of vectors and a threshold l and we
want to decide if one vector from each
set if there's one vector from each set
such that their inner product is at
least L
to reduce this to stable matching we
take forever you and you we create a man
msub you with attribute and weight
values given by you and similar we take
for every V and V we create a woman with
attribute and weight values V so in this
setting each man will prefer the woman a
woman who possesses the attributes that
he possesses and vice versa so in
particular if menu is more preferred
than man u prime by woman V then the
inner product of u and v is greater than
the inner product of U Prime and V and
the same holds for the women so how the
reduction works is we take our vectors
we create our men and women associated
with those vectors and then we find the
stable matching and the claim is we only
need to check this stable pairs to see
if any of them are at least L and that
will allow us to answer the question to
see this suppose that all of them were
less than L but there was some pair with
inner product l now based on this fact
here you three would prefer v2 over v1
v3 and the woman v2 would prefer man you
three over man you one so these two
would be in a blocking pair and they
would have so this matching is not
stable so therefore we only need to look
at the stable pairs and there's only a
linear number of those to check to find
a vector with inner product two vectors
with inner product at least L and the
reduction for the verifying stable
matching works similarly we need a few
more gadgets
so now I'll show the d-list stability
verification so here we have our example
preferences and now we're given a target
matching that we want to check if it's
stable or not and this matching is man
one is matched with women one man two
with woman 2 etc and we have an ordered
en algorithm which I'll go through right
now so first we'll compare each pair of
lists of the list of men with a list of
women so I'll lay out the men according
to list Sigma 1 and then the women
according to PI 1 then the men Sigma 2
pi 2 and then I'll have one extra copy
of Sigma one just because this is a
two-dimensional surface that doesn't
wrap around what we do is we draw an
edge an arrow from each man to the his
partner in the list that he cares about
so man one cares about PI 1 so we draw
from man 12 woman 1 in pi-1 and man one
two women 1 and PI 1 again and woman one
cares about Sigma 2 so we have the
arrows from women 1 to Sigma 2 and we do
this for each pair in our matching then
we look we look at each pair of lists in
particular let's look at the list Sigma
2 and PI to you can see that there's
these two edges are crossing in the
downward direction what that means is
that those two are in a blocking a pair
to see this first observe that the the
reason those arrows are there is because
women for cares about Sigma 2 and man 3
cares about pi 2 and the fact that
they're pointing below each other in the
list means that they did worse than each
other so both of them could improve by
being matched with each other and we
have a blocking pair so we know that
this is not stable and the claim is that
these are the this is the only case when
you have a blocking pair if there are
two downward crossing arrows so let's
look at a different matching since man 3
and woman for were in a blocking pair
let's match them together and see if
this matching is stable using the same
algorithm we draw our arrows again and
with a quick inspection you can see that
there's no downward crossing arrows
anymore so this is a stable matching so
we're comparing each pair of lists so
that's d squared pairs of lists however
if we if we're a little bit smart about
it we can figure out that we can only we
can make it so that we only have to
process the arrows and there's a total
of DN arrows or two DN arrows so this
gives us an order DN algorithm
finally for our d attribute algorithms I
don't have time to say a lot about it
but the general idea is that we convert
it to the race shooting problem the race
shooting problem is where you're given a
set of lines or hyper planes and you
shoot array from positive infinity and
the sea witch which line is hit first by
that ray and what we do is we take in
the one-sided case for finding a stable
matching since the women all use the
same preference list whoever whatever
man is at the top he will get his first
choice because every woman wants him so
so we can iteratively take find so we
can lay the women out as lines in the
plane and then each man is array which
we shoot a positive infinity and the
first woman that he intersects is his
top choice and matousek and squash cough
and others have developed some dynamic
data structures for ray shooting which
is allow us to do this in sub quadratic
time and the verification is again
similar but it's a higher dimensional
since we have to take into account the
preferences of the women and the men at
the same time
so there's an interesting gap between
finding and verifying the stable
matching in our algorithms here for
exempt for the D attribute model we have
a one-sided finding algorithm but we
have a two-sided verification so that
the verification is is better than that
the algorithm for finding a stable
matching and in the d-list we have no no
sub quadratic algorithm for finding a
stable matching and but we have an
optimal verification algorithm ordered d
times n so this raises an interesting
question which i think is interesting
regardless of how it could get answered
ideally we'll find we could find better
algorithms for finding a stable matching
that would match the verification ones
but if we can't find any and especially
if we could prove that you can't find
any then it would create a distinction
between finding and verification in the
D attribute or d-list model and that
distinction is not present in the
general stable matching because in
general stable matching finding is as
hard as verifying so there's future
directions we'd ideally like to find sub
quadratic algorithms for finding and a
stable matching in the full d attribute
case since we have a verification
algorithm we would like to get a
matching search algorithm and in
particular though the two lists case is
still open which seems like it's not
that hard there's only four list total
and somehow you have to find a simple
matching but there's there's some
complications there that if thus far
prevented us from finding us match an
algorithm for that or if we could prove
that any of these are hard then that
would close the gap as well we also like
to look at other sixteenth preference
models that might also be linear time
linear space have some sort of natural
interpretation or economic meaning and
might also lead to faster algorithms for
stable matching and finally we'd like to
apply our attribute models to others
preference markets for example they're
stable roommates where
you only have one set of people that
want to pair up amongst themselves or
the housing allocation market where only
one side of the market has preferences
so thanks for listening type of
questions
have you thought about incentive oh yeah
well for the I guess so far the yeah so
in the general stable matching there's
definitely incentive issues I think for
the algorithms that we have there
there's not a lot of I want to say that
it's similar enough that the same
incentive properties hold as the general
case if we did have a and obviously for
verification there's no real incentive
going on because you're just trying to
check if it's a stable matching with
with our finding algorithm I think the
case is special enough that there's less
incentive I mean you're assuming you're
already assuming that the women have a
fixed reference list so the women can't
deviate and the men are already getting
their best choice they can so so there's
no real incentive issues there but if we
could come up with one for the two lists
case and that actually actually that
actually we have thought about it a
little bit and we have an example of the
two lists case where if say the men are
proposing the women can get a better
matching if one of them lies about which
lists use like if that's the only thing
the only thing that the women are
allowed to do is lie about which lists
they're not allowed like rearrange the
list or anything that's the only thing
they do is lie than even then they can
improve their matching so yeah
but thanks